From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African-American History and Culture.
Today is Monday, July 18, 2011. My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm in Midtown Manhattan with a video videographer John Bishop to do an oral history interview for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is an undertaking of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African-American History and Culture.
And we're just really delighted and honored to be with you today, Professor Jack Greenberg, to talk about some very, very interesting Civil Rights history and your role in a lot of that history.
Thanks for meeting with us.
I thought I might start and have you just talk a little bit about how you evaluated the choice to join NAACP Legal Defense and Educational Fund as a law school graduate in 49?
Well, implicitly, I really made that choice before 49. I'd started a Columbia Law School with no thought of being a Civil Rights lawyer because there was no such thing.
I thought I would maybe do labor law or things that later would come under the label of Civil Rights.
But I had a professor at the time, Walter Gellhorn, who gave a seminar, which he called Legal Survey.
And in Legal Survey, students worked for Civil Liberty, Civil Rights Lawyers, again, that label hadn't attached to anyone at that time.
It was sort of a precursor of clinical legal education. We were working on real cases.
And I saw this course listed on the Bulletin Board. And I immediately ran our Silicon Recall, running up two flights of stairs.
It was Professor Gellhorn's office. It was coming and rolled in the course. A curious bit of history that this Smithsonian would be interested in is why he named it Legal Survey.
He said if he called it Civil Rights or Civil Liberties, the faculty might not permit him to teach it.
Because in those days, if you were a Civil Libertarian or Civil Rights advocate, you ran the risk of being called a Communist.
And in fact, Professor Gellhorn himself was summoned down to Congress on two occasions, to swear, I am not and never have been a member of the Communist Party.
So I took this course. And since the subject matter of the course has changed from week to week, depending on the cases you were working on, I took it for four semesters.
And it became chairman of the student body taking that course.
As I got out of law school, well, to make the long story very short, I had worked on some legal defense when cases.
And there weren't a lot of lawyers doing that. Legal defense when at that time had three or four of the lawyers.
The American Civil Liberties Union, which now has hundreds of lawyers, had a single lawyer. There were three Jewish organizations that respectively had three and one and one lawyers.
And that's all there was in the whole US, except some individual lawyers who handled some civil rights cases.
Anyway, one of the lawyers at NAACP Legal Defense and Educational Fund, her name was Marian Wynne Perry, was Marian Wynne Perry.
And it got some official position with New York State, and it required him to be an opening new year.
And so she resigned, and it was an opening. And the third in March of last, the whole of the yellow one to recommend somebody, and he recommended me.
And so that's all I got there. So I was at a disposition to do it, because I took this seminar for four semesters, but I hadn't planned to do it.
He's not exactly planning for a career in which there were six lawyers in the whole country doing it.
Okay, we're back after a short break.
Well, if I was a Greenberg, I thought I would extend the theme by asking to describe that small band of NAACP Legal Defense and Educational Fund attorneys.
I'm obviously under the very good Marshall's direction there, and in 49 when you join, as you say, it's just a couple of folks.
Right, there was so good. Even at that point, they had become a national figure, because he'd won the restrictive covenant cases.
So I'd describe it if you asked me to. He'd won some of the big voting rights case, and also, he had his first assistant who was Robert L. Carter, who was a judge here in New York.
I had a time of retire.
Another fellow called Franklin H. Williams, who later went on to another position in the NAACP, and then became ambassador to Ghana, and the head of the foundation, Phelps Stokes Foundation.
That was it, and it was me. There was also a woman there who was a full-time sociologist. I'm truly only law officer in the world, a sociologist, honest staff.
That was it.
At that time, I might say, we were part of the NAACP. We were a separate independent part, though the independence caused some tension between us and Roy Wilkins, the head of the NAACP.
But nevertheless, independent.
In 1957, we were related to tax exemption. We spun off, became entirely independent as the NAACP Legal Defense and Educational Fund.
And then later created some different kinds of tension.
Let me ask, as a young lawyer, you were very quickly in the midst of a lot of very significant litigation in schools, and particularly in schools, obviously in the early 50s.
I think you and Robert L. Carter tried the Kansas schools case out in Topeka, Kansas.
That's right.
Can you share some recollections of that experience?
Oh, yeah. Well, I think the things you remember about the case and not the important things, because the important things are part of history, so you don't have to be mentioning them again.
The Kansas had a peculiar statute. It was an Kansas school segregation statute.
The schools were required to be segregated by law in Kansas, high schools, or high school systems, could opt to be segregated, and Kansas had taken that option.
We tried the case on two different tracks, as we did, all the other cases.
That is to show that the black schools were not equal to the white schools, in which we make all tangible, measurable respects.
Number of books, teachers, salaries, numbers, where feet, gymnasium, playing ground, curriculum, laboratories, things like that.
But then we also tried it on the basis of urging the court, with the help of expert witnesses, to understand that segregation itself constituted inequality.
I know you probably have told this story many times, but let me ask you just to recall your reaction when the Brown v. Board of Education finally came down in May of 54.
Well, that was a long time from the argument, which was 50-51, really.
And then we appealed to the Supreme Court in 52, and then argued two more times after that.
Everybody was kind of stunned by it.
We won lots of cases before in the sense of big rocket celebrations, and we just sort of silenced the sentence that everybody would have.
I think stunned is the only word, a cosmic decision.
And later turned out to be even more cosmic, then.
We understood we were the case, the challenge, school segregation.
It turned out the decision swept away all state-imposed segregation.
Were you surprised by the vehement of the pattern of reaction that arose in the late 50s across the South to early efforts to desegregate schools?
That's right, there were other cases like that that had been won in the following higher education law schools, graduate schools, voting, and then in lower courses, things like golf courses, beaches, theaters.
And there was sort of grudging acceptance of those.
And the cases, those earlier cases did not involve any mass numbers of people.
The higher education cases involved one or two people, but integrating a school system, large numbers, and more horrible to the segregationists were.
And then women going to school together, boys and girls.
The biggest taboo was any kind of contact between the sexes.
I'm interested to have you talk a little bit about how you measure the landscape of possibility when you became director council in 61.
Well by then a lot of things had happened.
61, the civil rights movement had begun.
And the students were being sitting in North Carolina, as you well know, and elsewhere in the South.
And it was picking up like wildfire all over the country.
And they were being arrested. And there were no ready defenses for them, because they had never been necessary to defend anybody against anything like that.
But we understood the Constitution and leave Alaska pretty well.
And so we were ready with a bunch of defenses.
And we, I might say, we ended up by the time the civil rights movement.
I don't know what I've ever ended by the time it reached some measurable stopping point.
We represented about 3500 people and got them all acquitted.
And neglected as we were talking there for a minute about the late 50s, I wanted to ask and have you, um, discussed, you published in 59 race relations in American law.
That's right. Which was an unprecedented volume.
Can you talk a little bit about the effort to do that work, to do that volume and what you were trying to do with it?
Well a lot of these things, you don't have any ambitions beyond the thing itself, because you can't tell what's going to happen.
But I was practicing civil rights law, and I was impressed by the fact that there was no book on civil rights law.
And I was handling cases in all the areas that the book covered.
Essentially I took my knowledge of those cases and put them into the book, which was the first one in my civil rights law since about 1919.
What reaction did the book receive?
It was curious in some ways. They've got excellent reviews.
But it was considered to be a hot topic. For example, the Columbia Law Review did something I haven't seen them do or any other law review.
Before, since they published a pro and anti-review as if we were a controversial subject.
And then there was some academics who had used on civil rights.
There was one Herbert Wechsler, a famous article called Toward Neutral Principles of Constitutional Law".
And then there was a legal philosopher at NYU, Edmond Cahn, who wrote a book.
Essentially an article, anyway, attacking the Brown v. Board of Education for its use of social science data.
Anyway, I didn't see how I could have anything against what I'd written.
And it would be quite a clue to get them to review the book.
So I sent them a copy and asked what they would review.
And he called me and asked me to come to his office.
And he said, he wants them to know that he thought the book was an excellent book.
But he didn't feel he could review it objectively with his son.
He was white and married a black woman.
I said, well, I didn't think that should make any difference.
I really didn't want to go.
Can you move again to the early 60s?
You've written and used the phrase of movement in some respects.
And those after February 1960, really shifted from the courts and into the streets there for many years.
Oh, yeah.
And of course, you traveled extensively, had been traveling extensively from New York, from the time you joined the LDF.
Are there any episodes or memories that really stand out in your mind as exemplary or particularly vivid in recalling those early years of the 60s when the movement was really active in the streets?
Well, part of the traveling was, of course, going on railroads or airplanes.
And the railroads were segregated at the beginning.
Airplanes weren't but a good many airport terminals were even north-throw line, even at federal facilities.
So that was something no-worthy.
And we brought a number of cases, a fair number of cases, to desegregate airports and protocol bringing a case.
Desegregate in the airport in Atlanta.
Plainfacures there, the name of Koch, so it was Koch against City of Atlanta, which is the home of Koch of Koch.
And I brought a case against the airport in New Orleans.
My co-counsel was A.P. Tureaud, who were a period of time, was the only black lawyer in New Orleans.
A Tura, well, I didn't think it was his granddaughter, I think he was two-year-old, so that's been his daughter.
He brought his granddaughter to the airport after he won the case.
And she ran off just gleefully.
She was able to buy an ice cream cone there.
Something she'd never been able to do before.
You mentioned Attorney Tura, which reminds me of the network of cooperating attorneys at the LVF developed over the years.
And pioneering black attorneys in the South, who would very courageously take cases and conjunction with Legal Defense Fund.
But I also want to ask, in 63 on your own initiative as Director Counsel, you launched a new training program that would become quite a significant mechanism for extending the numbers of black attorneys in the South.
Oh, yeah, I'm talking about that a little bit.
There were a lot of cities where there was no black lawyer at all, or maybe one.
But an amazing number that was done at all.
And I got some money from a foundation.
The black lawyer was a go set up a practice in a place where there were no black lawyers.
We give him $10,000 to buy a typewriter, a rug, and some law books.
We got some great stars out of that.
There were Julius Chambers.
And then one of Mel Watt.
No, what?
And then another congressman in Georgia, in the world, his name, I think even the moment,
he didn't want to, he wanted to set a practice in Atlanta, but by then there were a handful of black lawyers in Atlanta.
And I originally went to some places.
He went to Columbus.
He was the only black lawyer.
And he's now the congressman from...
from Columbus.
Marian Wright Edelman also was in Columbus.
Marian Wright Edelman?
Yes, (Marian) Wright was one of the aces. She was terrific.
And in the run-up towards the Civil Rights Act of 64, particularly saved by 63 when Kennedy has introduced legislation,
some bill appears increasingly likely to clear the congress.
It's always not perfectly certain, but there's momentum in that direction, particularly after Kennedy's assassination, obviously.
And the Legal Defense Fund, under your direction, is really working hard to craft a litigation program that will encompass all of this new legal terrain.
That's right.
And I'd love to have you describe how you were thinking about new opportunities and what you, the scope of what you hoped maybe to be able to do.
Well, one of the things that covered the public accommodation was restaurants, bar, theaters, and so forth.
That was pretty easy, because the ice cream parlors and restaurants were happy to get the business.
People would say that the market would take care of it, but the market did not take care of it.
Nobody wanted to stick his neck out first.
So we did not have a lot of relief, no real resistance. There was some emphasis on subterfuges.
A lot of hotels set up private clubs within the hotel.
And I would recall going to a town and being white, checking in the hotel, and being a hand at a membership card in the club,
and just sort of came with being white and registering in the hotel.
And the black person registered with me, never been.
Well, that was pretty transparent, so it took a little bit of a while to figure out that's always going on.
The public accommodation was just titled to easy.
Title VII of the Civil Rights Act of 1964 was employment, and that, of course, we were opposed not only to employers who may not have wanted to employ blacks.
But many of them didn't care.
We'll be just as happy to employ blacks as employ whites, but we had a confront the fact that the labor unions,
which on the national level, were very pro civil rights, on the local level were segregated, white locals and black locals.
And white locals in one, blacks in, and black locals often didn't want to lose their members to the white local.
So that was a problem.
We had some of our bitterest cases against the labor unions.
Are you feeling comfortable enough for the white and the heat now?
Okay.
We're back after short break.
I'll come back to ask another question or two about Title VII of the Civil Rights Act of 1964 employment later in the interview,
obviously you were attempting in those years to find some way forward with schools.
And Title VI helped maybe a little bit on that front, but the school's question would remain very difficult for the late 60s.
That's right.
A lot of white people didn't want to think it's the old school of black kids.
And it didn't take a lot to stir up enough opposition.
So we got an order to desegate the schools, they'd be resistance, and they'd be litigated, it was very vigorously.
And none would involve schools, but the real estate values that depend upon the schools in the neighborhood,
who involved a graduate or a property people alone.
And these cases were vigorously litigated and became a subject of big political fights.
They called it Southern Strategy. He was going to be opposed to integration.
He had no ideological convictions about this.
He just assumed he segregated, and non-secretly he wanted to do it, would work for him.
After we took a case of Supreme Court, essentially defeating him and the Congress won the case.
He didn't get in the way, and we had very widespread desegregation, Alexander v. Holmes County Board of Education.
We really enjoyed taking that case.
It's a great example of how the laws, all legal documents are interconnected.
The way the case came up was we had won some cases which indicated that the next round of cases might lead to a certain kind of conflict.
Supreme Court decision, that score, even a court of appeal decision, that schools had to be desegregated immediately.
And we're Nixon, or rather Senator Senator John C. Stennis, after whom a recent aircraft carrier has been named.
Stennis, so this is going to happen. He refused to bring the armed services appropriation built to the floor of the Senate.
Because he told the President that his people in Mississippi need him down there to commune with him.
Nixon had to ask his secretary of health education, a welfare, to ask the court of appeals to send the cases back to the district court without deciding him.
And in the district court, then reconsider whether or not they should order immediate desegregation.
And that's what happened.
His secretary, I think Robert H. Finch was his name, asked the court of appeals, who's the Justice Department, to not decide the cases.
Well, at that point, he were option to go with the Supreme Court as very limited because the law is that Supreme Court here cases from a final judgment.
And the thing that Nixon was asking for was that there be no final judgment.
So we had to appeal from the absence of the final judgment, the decision of the final judgment.
Well, there is an ancient common law writ called certiorari.
It's not the rid of certiorari, that's in a statute which Supreme Court uses to review almost every case it gets.
But there's another statute which says that all the writs on the common law are available in the federal courts.
And the ancient rid of certiorari, not the statutory certiorari, but for the common law certiorari.
It says you can bring any case to any court you want.
No, it doesn't happen very often, it doesn't happen successfully.
So I still recall what I call Marshal Foch telling the staff.
My left flank is in certiorari, my right flank is under attack, my center collapses.
And as Marshall Farge said at the second battle of the marne, my attack.
And we did, and the court agreed to hear and rule with us.
The further high water mark on schools, of course, would be Swann v. Charlotte-Mecklenburg Board of Education, the Swann v. Charlotte-Mecklenburg Board of Education Charlotte Schools case 1971.
And I wonder if you can share your recollections with Swann v. Charlotte-Mecklenburg Board of Education case and it's significant, particularly on bus fare.
Well, Swann v. Charlotte-Mecklenburg Board of Education was the first substance of case, the court heard, and I decided to get it.
And Chief Chief Justice Earl Warren Burger wrote a very long-guard opinion in which he called for quotas and busing and integration of teachers and everything that any civil rights advocate ever asked for.
That was his first opinion after Nixon had appointed him.
So Swann v. Charlotte-Mecklenburg Board of Education, but as the case began in the Supreme Court, it was not at all certain we would win the case.
Following the argument, the preliminary vote among the judges was that they would uphold the lower court, they would not enter the order we finally saw.
But as the conference is among the judges went on, Berger, who was the leader of a minority decision, found himself outvoted by the other judges.
(Chief Justice) Earl Warren told me. I was told of all the parties. He said, there he stood naked.
And he had a turn this evening.
Let's take a brief break.
We're back after short break. You were just saying that Chief Chief Justice Earl Warren had remarked to you that Chief Chief Justice Earl Warren Burger stood naked.
So no vote. Well, he's in the dissent. But if he's in the dissent, he can't decide the opinion.
And he wants to control the opinion. So he switched his vote and decided to vote. There's a court went, so he could have signed the opinion to himself.
Which is what he did. And he signed it to himself. But he wrote something in the last paragraph of the opinion.
I said, one of these days, this is going to have to come to an end. And were they going to reconsider it? And not going to require anybody to do anything.
Something that couldn't really predict how it was going to come out. But after about 10, 15 years, that's what happened. The line on that last paragraph was gone.
I want to ask, thinking about schools, I know the LVF I think was only in one of these two cases. But I'm interested in your thoughts about thinking about how the schools question arked forward from Swann v. Charlotte-Mecklenburg Board of Education.
As you say, it kind of maybe reached a high water in around 1980 or so. And then the numbers shifted back. And the court shifted back on the question.
But I'm thinking about Milliken v. Bradley v. Bradley in 74 in San Antonio Independent School District v. San Antonio Independent School District v. Rodriguez in 75, the first being the Metropolitan Consultation question, obviously.
And the second one, Alex San Antonio being the funding question. And I'm interested in your thoughts on those cases and how you gauge their significance.
Well, Milliken v. Bradley v. Bradley was significant in that it made the distinguishing point between city and suburbs. Just the political boundary between them.
It was obviously he had two families living each like 50 yards on the US side of the boundary line. The distance is not very great.
Two different political systems, one for one county, one for another. But he didn't work that out.
So obviously the court was making the boundary the city and the suburbs having separate different kinds of school systems.
And that was really a political decision.
Excuse me one second.
We had to break there for a moment. You were talking about Milliken v. Bradley v. Bradley.
So the decision to make.